the 49ers had an issue where they had a
guy who wanted out it wasn't that long
ago that raheem mostert had demanded a
trade uh he got a deal done to stick
around in san francisco i haven't seen
the numbers yet the indications are it
wasn't a great deal it was just kind of
a let's do something to make up here and
get rahim mostar feeling better about
where he is with the 49ers maybe some
money got moved around look this is a
team that can get it done with a bunch
of running backs and that was my
reaction when mostert made his power
play right they'll just move on to
somebody else they still got their
secret weapon in jerick mckinnon who's
been on the roster for two years and had
that torn acl from early in 2019 like
the last practice before the start of
the week one preparations um if
mckinnon's healthy you've got other guys
you really don't need rahim mostly i
know he had that huge game in the
postseason against the packers but you
know how that offense is you just put
it's it's we talked about it yesterday
with the vikings and dalvin cook you
just put somebody else in and if that
guy's banged up you put somebody else in
and if that guy's banged up you put
somebody else in and everybody you put
in is going to get it done yeah well no
you're right it's the shanahan run
scheme is it's it's famous it's special
i mean we know that you know whether
what you're right kubiak shannon kyle
shanahan mike shannon whatever i mean
they just they gash people every year
with whatever offense they're in and it
just doesn't seem to matter you know
with a guy like rahim mozart you know
this is something i i can't remember
mike if i said this on my podcast last
week or but i was like i was shocked
when i heard like the trade demand and
you know the agent and what i chalked it
up to on my podcast i think i explained
it to i said something was lost in
communication here because i know for a
fact like raheem mozart's one of one of
kyle shanahan's favorite players like
ever he loves he loves him you know i
mean he gave him a new contract last
year and one of the things that i think
ahmed fareed asked me on the podcast
he's like well what would you say to him
i was like i would tell rahim mozart to
call kyle because to me it just looked
like something was lost like people were
talking to the wrong people and he just
needed to get into kyle's ear now the
contract details you're right we don't
know what they are you know uh it it's
reading to me like it's incentive based
and you know i i know my buddy kyle
shanahan when he likes the player
and and really is all in on the person
and the player he'll he'll do his best
to you know give the guy as much money
as he can or make it happen you know and
again
i i don't know if it was a great deal or
whatever it was but let's also take into
account you know like you said the 49ers
got a special team rahim mozart you
don't want to give that up they're
special with running backs because of
shanahan and the running scheme and the
offensive line and raheem moser you've
been on six or seven different teams
already or five or whatever it is you
finally got a damn spot where you've
carved out a niche so i'm glad it worked
out i'm glad i worked out for the 49ers
and my buddy and i just from everything
i've heard raheem mozart and what he's
been through i'm rooting for him too
there is a general rule of thumb in
league circles that if the details of a
contract don't emerge within 24 hours
after the news of the contract emerges
it's not a good contract for the player
so we'll see yeah and that means it's a
good contract for the team we'll see
what the details of the raheem mostar
contract are it's not like he had a lot
of leverage and at the end of the day
there are plenty of other guys who can
run the football for the san francisco
49ers but it's good for them to keep
most dirt happy or at least as happy as
he can possibly be and keep him in the
fold and this 49ers team you know we're
doing the the state of the franchise
it's gonna be a long time to get to the
49ers get him at number two chris i mean
they're bringing a lot of guys back
and and even though going back to zero
and zero after you
you have that special season and it was
so hard to get the number one seed and
it came down to the last game of the
regular season that there's a stability
there there's a confidence there there's
a sense there that they're just going to
pick up where they left off last year
yeah i i mean yeah we've heard some of
the comments you know kyle's shanahan's
made during the off season i mean
they're they're a phenomenal football
team yeah they're set right now you know
we got to see them in person in january
they're impressive looking in person
they got a special emotion about them
you know they're one of those teams
right now where i just and just in
sports in general i sit here and think
and go man you know just talk about bad
luck i mean it's just this this could be
a year that affects legacies forever and
ever you know you know just across the
board but yeah just think about them
them the chiefs i just look at you man
we're in the super bowl window we got
patrick mahomes and you know with the
49ers we got this great defense and we
might not even be able to play this year
like and we might have you know
capitalized on this team that we've you
know worked so hard to build you know
that's where i feel bad for coaches
athletes and i feel bad for lebron james
on a great team in the lakers here he is
i don't know what the hell is going to
happen it's just you know tom brady this
might be his last year if he can't play
it's just uh it's a shame that way and
the 49ers are one of those teams i look
at and go man that would really stink if
they couldn't play football when you
have a team that is certainly built to
be in a super bowl or win a super bowl
once again
or or if you have a season that is rife
with competitive imbalance and that has
some you know unfairness in various
forms and fashions at the end of the day
though as we talked about last hour it
will be a complete season in that they
will find a way to hand out a trophy and
there may or may not be an asterisk
applied to it there's never been an
asterisk applied to the washington
super bowl trophy from 82 or the
washington super bowl trophy from 87.
so you know it's fitting that washington
would win the super bowl this year
another crazy upside down season
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports